As you have seen in this lesson,
the distribution of daily returns for
stocks and the market look
very similar to a Gaussian.
This property persists when we
look at weekly, monthly, and
annual returns as well.
If they were really Gaussian we'd say
the returns were normally distributed.
In many cases in financial
research we assume the returns
are normally distributed.
But this can be dangerous
because it ignores kurtosis or
the probability in the tails.
In the early 2000s investment banks
built bonds based on mortgages.
They assumed that
the distribution of returns for
these mortgages was
normally distributed.
On that basis they were able
to show that these bonds had
a very low probability of default.
But they made two mistakes.
First, they assumed that the return of
each of these mortgages was independent,
and two that this return would
be normally distributed.
Both of these assumptions
proved to be wrong,
as massive numbers of homeowners
defaulted on their mortgages.
It was these defaults that precipitated
the great recession of 2008.